cloud sql insights is a simple
open tool that helps developers quickly
understand and resolve database
performance issues on cloud sql
it provides developers with a single
interface for self-service
application-centric monitoring and
diagnosis of database performance issues
to access insights i can click query
insights
in the left navigation i'm going to walk
you through how to use insights to
identify and diagnose a database
performance problem in an application
in this scenario i'm an application
developer on a team that developed a
ride sharing application
we've gotten a report from some of our
users so the application is running
slowly
let's look at how i can use insights to
investigate and find the cause of the
problem
looking at the top level query insights
dashboard i'll start with the database
load all queries graph
which can help me visually identify
performance problems or spikes in
database load
the database load graph confirms that
there's a problem that started happening
around 12 o'clock
the colors in the graph help me see that
there's an increase in cpu
and an even larger increase in lock
weight now i need to find out which
query is causing the problem
what the root cause of the problem is
and where in my application code the
problem lies
to try to identify which query is
causing the problem i'll start with the
queries table
the queries table contains normalized
queries for the time frame selected
the queries in the table are sorted by
total execution time by default
but i can also filter it by other
criteria like cpu time
io weight or lock weight the first query
in the table certainly stands out as its
total execution time is much larger than
the rest of the entries
like many modern applications this
application consists of several
different services
and i want to know which one is causing
the performance problem
traditional monitoring tools only
provide a query centric view of
performance
with insights i can toggle from the
queries table to the tags table
to see a list of queries tagged by
business logic giving me an application
centric view
the tags table is especially helpful to
me as a developer
since this application was built using
django's orm rather than by writing the
sql queries myself
insights uses sql commenter an open
source library which provides
instrumentation and wrappers
to augment sql from frameworks and orms
if your application is using one of the
supported orms
the queries are automatically tagged
with little to no change to your
application code
so you're more easily able to identify
query load
and pinpoint where the problem may lie
in your application
since you can see information like
actions controllers and routes
the first tag query for the payment
charge controller looks like it's the
problem
now that i've identified that this is
likely the slow query i want to find out
why it's slow i'm going to click through
to see more details for this tag query
insights include sample executed query
plans which i can use to understand why
the query is slow
query plans can be complex and difficult
to understand
but insights provides visual query plans
that can help me easily detect which
part of the query is slow
each part of the query shows the latency
rows returned and the cost for that
operation
in this query an update is happening the
modify table looks to be contributing
the most the latency because of locking
contention
now that we've identified the slow query
and the cause let's confirm the source
of the problem
insights provides in-context
visualization of end-to-end tracing
to help me find which application code
is causing the problem
in addition to being able to see the
controller and route it can also help me
understand if a particular host
or user is the source of a problem while
i'm viewing the trace visualization from
within
insights in this example insights
complements your existing apm
and observability tools insights
provides database metrics and traces
through the open standard
open telemetry and cloud monitoring and
cloud trace apis
this makes it easy to do end-to-end
tracing in your existing tools
in this video we've looked at ways you
can use cloud sql insights to help with
diagnosing and troubleshooting
application performance issues
all from a single intuitive ui in the
description below the video
you'll find links to a blog post
introducing insights
and the documentation for cloud sql
insights and sql commenter
or you can click on the code lab to try
it out for yourself